At any given moment, we
humans have two choices
ortwo spirals that
are available to us.
The first is the
toilet vortex.
The toilet vortex
might startlike this.
You're picking on
yourself because
you don't like the way
you look in the mirror.
You'reunhappy with your
level of productivity
or you have failed to
achieve ketosis, whatever.
And then you take that
out on other people
and then you are feeling
more miserable,
andthen
down you go.
The vastly superior
alternative is what
I call the cheesy
upward spiral.
As yourinner weather
gets balmier,
that shows up in your
relationships with other people.
And becauserelationships are probably
the most important variable when
it comes to human flourishing,
your inner weather improves even further
and up you go. And that
is the whole pointhere.
Self-love, properly understood,
not as narcissism,
but as having your own
back, is not selfish.
It makes you better at
loving other people.
And that makesyou more
generous and more available.